you
hi everyone is cherry on December 18
1963 20 year-old Bobby Fischer playing
with the black pieces already a very
well established Grandmaster to say the
least
created a 21 move brilliancy against
Robert Byrne burn at the time of this
game was an international master less
than one year after this game was played
Byrne became a grandmaster this game was
played at the United States Chess
Championship held in New York this was a
round three game Fischer won his first
two rounds and would not stop winning
Fischer would go on to a perfect 11 for
11 at the 1963 / 64 United States Chess
Championship this tournament actually
spilled over into the New Year just to
put this dominant performance into
perspective while that great big ball
was falling in New York to ring in the
New Year Fischer already had this
tournament won he could not be caught
his nearest competitor was Larry Evans
once the final standings were in Larry
Evans was three and a half points behind
Fisher seven and a half out of 11
one last note is that this performance
is one that is honored today at u.s.
chess championships there's a thing
called the Fischer prize because of this
great performance the Fischer prize is
awarded to any player who is brilliant
enough to go perfect at the US
Championship that has yet to happen no
one has gone perfect or in other words
no one has been awarded that $64,000
prize
let's dive in and see this round three
brilliancy
burn kicks off with d4
strong foothold in the center
Fisher does not allow an ideal pond
center
see for both players prepare a kingside
Fein keto and Fischer is not too quick
to simply swing the bat completely
around typically g6 is immediately
followed up with Bishop g7 but not here
c6 instead black is taking some time out
to ensure that he too can establish a
foothold in the center on d5 black must
be timely with this if he wants to
establish a pawn in the center playing
Bishop g7 and c6 only one move later
well now black has to contend with a
pawn trio so first it's c6 d v next and
there we go a d4 versus d5 battle Knight
c3 some natural moves coming in now only
at this stage move six Bishop g7 III
castles Knight to e2 knight c6 castles
and what should each side do with the
bishops let's see
b6 b3 will have a little bit of copycat
going on Bishop a6 Bishop a3 when is
this going to end
we're 11 moves in and just 10 moves out
before this game being over this is a
very interesting position
it's surprising to me
you know before I reviewed the game III
knew it's 21 moves and at this point
here we're at move 11 and take note of
the great symmetry that is present in
this position
take note specifically to the a file the
file C file D file G file and H file
what's going on with all of those files
if you are to draw a horizontal line
that cuts between ranks four and five
and were to fold this board onto itself
those six highlighted files the pieces
the pawns would be mapped on to one
another there is symmetry with each of
those six highlighted files why am i
drawing attention to this it's because
we need to look at this position where
there are imbalances it's quite often
the case that in very symmetrical
positions such as this one things go
about very slowly it's often in a bit of
a maneuvering game not a lot of let's
say great tactics or fireworks things of
course can change but there is a great
amount of symmetry here so in order to
let's say establish a plan you know what
should white do what should black - we
need to focus on where there are
differences where there are imbalances
and where there are imbalances in this
position is the F file and the e file so
I just want to draw some attention to
where exactly there are differences the
difference is in this position lie with
the King Knights their posts our
differences they don't map up let's say
with one another if we were to fold this
board nor would the e pawns this is
where there are some differences okay so
with some attention to these differences
let's see how maybe one could go about
formulating a plan fisher's xi move is
rook to e8
now there are a couple ideas behind this
one you're getting out of a pin you know
want that sniper taking out the rook as
soon as the pawn moves so the rooks on a
better square and Fischer is ready to
set into motion the e pawn and say you
know what you're epon took one step I'm
going to show you how to move an e pawn
I'm gonna go two steps and engage in the
center create some tension some heat on
that d4 square
so this is what black has in mind and a
little bit later we'll see that the
third-ranked Knight will play a very
significant role versus this second
ranked Knight being just one rank
further up the board will matter
Queen to d2 follows move 12 E 5 on board
this is a very tense moment right here
after takes takes we now have a great
imbalance doesn't take much for things
to change in a great way in a chess
position 1 pawn exchange and there's a
great reassessment that needs to be done
we have a case now where black has an
isolated pawn this is a potential you
know there's always this question is
that a liability is it an asset it's to
be determined black at the moment enjoys
a little bit more space black with his
last move has improved the knight by one
rank this Knight is still sitting on the
c3 square let's see what follows rook on
F to d1 you know do you move this rook
here or this rook here it seems to make
a lot of sense to move this rook here
and with the idea of playing the other
rook here another reason for making that
move is to get out of a pin just as
black did with rook to e8 getting out of
harm's way getting out of the Bishop's
line of fire
but there is an issue with this decision
the better move here for white is to
actually bring the other rook over to d1
and this will soon be apparent we'll
soon see why this is the case so rook F
to d1
half-opened file throwing some more
pieces on that d5 pawn that isolated
pawn and now Fischer hops into this nice
intersection square on d3 and this night
sometimes noted as the octopus night
this is really striking at a lot of
squares within the white position and
well a couple ones still back on the
home ground here both he five and c5
he's striking out a lot of different
squares and there is one that is extra
sensitive Queen c2 follows and now we
have Knight takes f2 and what we're
observing now is a difference between
you know at that moment where you know
which rook should maybe go to D one if
this rook was still on f1 this capture
on f2 would not be good enough would be
bad because the rook can take the knight
but because this rook is now over here
on d1 the sacrifice is working this is a
winning shot and the fireworks are not
yet over the king is now lured out and
now accessible to what that third ranked
Knight that guy on f6 now pounces Knight
g4 check King g1 Knight takes c3 what do
we call that that's a family fork
hitting everything the Queen is saved
and we obviously take the rook or do we
this is one of the last main decision
points for team black
do you take the rook or not
take the rook you take the bishop
which one would you take you probably
know where I'm going with this by now
the rook held in your hand is worth five
the bishop held in your hand is worth
three but given this position
we need to view the pieces in a
different way
this bishop is well he's Fein kettled
he's on the kingside and that is where
the white king resides as well this
bishop is more like four points four and
a half maybe even more
he's invaluable in this specific case he
is an incredibly important defender to
the white king fisher understood this
and captures the bishop taking the rook
leads to an even position it's actually
saying that white would be a little bit
better he takes out the bishop not the
rook the bishop King takes Knight and
now there is only one good move for
black that maintains a decisive
advantage if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video see what move you would
play here as black
okay the move played by Fisher move 19
is
d for now if you spent some time on that
position I think there's a good chance
you would come up with that especially
if you kind of leaned on my earlier
advice about identifying imbalances
let's just take one step back back right
here D for was this last move but why is
D for played right now well where is
there a great imbalance here let's have
a look at the pieces where is the white
piece that will combat blacks light
square bishop it doesn't exist
black took that guy out white is without
their light square bishop
if black can activate their light square
bishop on the main diagonal the corner
to corner light square diagonal good
things are probably going to happen
white is going to be in some serious hot
water so you don't play here first
because 94 and that's like the no soup
for you move that pawns going nowhere
okay
first black make sure this file will be
opened right towards that white King
Knight takes pawn bishop b7 check King
to f1 is played
variation where one move out before
white actually resigns in the game King
to f1 is played
if King Ji Won is played we would have
Bishop takes Knight
Queen takes bishop and now a very nice
deflection tactic where's the defender
it's the rook it's defending the Queen
we try to deflect the defender rook e1
rook takes rook would be met with Queen
takes Queen and on King f2 we take the
Queen
and then we would take the rook in the
corner black is not only up the exchange
but also has a pawn in his pocket
but King to g1 was not played in the
game King f1 was played not too many
great choices here that bishop is a
killer
knifing right into the white camp
Queen to d7 move 21 is the last move
at this point resigns he knows what's
coming
and Fisher knows what's coming - there's
a beautiful brilliant sacrifice or a
beautiful combination that is just right
around the corner in this final position
from round three
Fisher was said to be quote bitterly
disappointed end quote
after his opponent resigned he wanted to
you know play this position now why
exactly well this is the variation he
wanted to see happen the big threat here
is that the black queen is ready to
knife in to the white king position on
h3 with the punch and from that post
it's facilitating a Bishop to h6 move
which is an absolute killer if we just
have a look currently the rook is taking
away what squares from the king these
two the bishop is taking away this one
the Queen when placed on h3 would be
taking away the square the King is
currently on and there are only two
other squares that black would need to
control before it's checkmate G 1 and F
2 who would do that the bishop and
that's how he would snake in pivoting on
e3 in controlling those other two
squares this is the variation Fisher
noted he wanted to see white play on
play Queen 2 f2 basically
getting out of that Bishop to h6 move
queen h3 would follow king g1 in now we
would have an absolute star move in this
position once more if this actually did
play out this is a good moment to go
ahead pause the video what would be the
winning shot in this position go ahead
pause the video if you would like okay
the winning shot from here is rook to e1
the Queen keep in mind has a big
responsibility namely to defend
checkmate rook takes rook and now Bishop
takes Knight would follow the Queen is
pinned to the king queen takes bishop
Queen ji - game over it didn't get that
far though I kind of understand yeah
bitterly disappointed I think it would
have been pretty cool to see that
actually pulled off you know played out
just a couple more moves but I thought
that this one was a this game is just
fantastic 11 moves in a lot of symmetry
present 10 moves later the games already
over how quickly things can change one
imbalance present in the position can
really change things up important to
recognize those imbalances and yeah that
can help you to ultimately produce a
plan time will put some good strategy so
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye
you